foreign
[Music]
I'm a virologist by training and today
we will be covering the topic of antigen
tests viral antigen tests and making an
emphasis in our experience during the
covert epidemic and the studies that we
have now undergo I represent idx20 this
is a startup in the area of Boston
Massachusetts
I'm the CEO and I represent a much
bigger larger team of excellent
scientists and colleagues
so the talk will be divided in giving
you an introduction of the problem we
could go over the history of what
antigen tests had been um for covid-19
epidemic we will then go into current
data that we have in clinical studies in
Massachusetts and we will talk about
image analysis methodologies and
conclusions the
[Music]
um
next slide wants to
give you an overview of the antigen test
problem and position what has happened
in particular antigen means protein and
antigen tests have proven to be a key
component for controlling viral spread
during the code epidemic but
there were not available early times in
the epidemic and even though this uh
today we have a lot of knowledge about
antigen tests that wasn't the case early
on
the several issues that impact the
regulatory approval such as their lower
accuracy compared to PCR and PCR is a
technique that detects the nucleic acid
of the virus not the protein
have to do with the variable performance
in the real world settings for antigen
tests especially among vulnerable
populations and they're limited
real-time reporting to the appropriate
Public Health authorities because
antigen tests are by definition very
simple do not require any machines do
not require any laboratory and are done
in the privacy of the home and that
requires its spread of information from
the user the person to that public
entity and that has been a challenge
also it's important to note that
due to the very difficult regulatory
process studies that correlate faster
and you know easy to do laboratory
validations of accuracy of the antigen
test and compared to the clinical
performance required by regulatory
science have not been
well documented or done therefore
hopefully what we address today it's of
interest and more important addresses a
a problem that has a public interest
um in addition these are very simple
tests but yet they're they're not that
completely simple in the sense that they
can offer uh much more and we'll go
hopefully over these uh topic today uh
in terms of why uh evaluation of a test
could be quite important or had
relevance in in the near future is
because the price of these tests could
be
um could be more affordable we hope that
or their vision is that by having more
numbers of these antigen tests in the
market will definitely come um open the
competition for lower price and
availability to the population
especially vulnerable populations
it's also important because it would
create standardized protocols to
validate the tests and
um across the board and not just in
United States but globally
and therefore lastly
it also increases the information that
currently we could acquire from an
antigen test because going through these
validation processes we will see how it
correlates the simple image analysis and
the intensity of the band that we all
know an antigen test looks like today
that test band over a white background
has much more information and that
information could be actually relevant
to the um outcome of the disease to The
Prompt medical treatment and therefore
has implications that are of relevance
okay so where and how do we go about
providing better
um
ways to validate this test so what we
did in this particular example that we
will be presenting today we we selected
a part or a geographical area this is
near Boston the city of Chelsea and the
City of Chelsea has very specific
characteristics in this graph we see how
the wave of
um kovid in a monthly basis during 2022
was a much higher impact in in Chelsea
City compared to the state of
Massachusetts
and this is because
Chelsea itself has an a few a few
problems uh population why wide it has
uh overcrowded Condition it's the second
most crowded city in Massachusetts it
has about 80 percent of the residents
consider essential workers that means
they have to go to work even during The
Surge of cases of covet
and in addition therefore the
incremental exposure to virus in
addition uh this uh city has over 60
percent of the Hispanic Latino residents
and immigrants which poses a challenge
for
um English barrier and socio-economical
barriers so we wanted to work with this
particular vulnerable population and
um now the how we do it for validations
of death
we can see here we proposed had to have
a weekly
protocol this is a clinical protocol
clinical study by which we work with the
residents of the
elderly senior housing this provided us
a good uh solid
cohort of people to follow over a year
we are right now about five months in
this project
and what it what it consists of is to
bring testing every week to their homes
their Lobby areas their building
have them
use a simple phone with a camera so it
is important to note that we are very
emphatic on the digital portion of these
antigen testing not just the performance
by a nurse or a doctor or a health
provider but by themselves by the people
themselves and be able to
propagate that information further
on their own
and once they test themselves with an
antigen tester as a cartoon of various
antigen tests we have in the project
these are antigen tests that have not
yet obtained in emergency use
authorization in the United States but
had been already validated to be highly
performing tests
and then after that if every week if
that person becomes positive that person
goes home isolates and it gets tested
for eight consecutive times every day
every single point of that
um event is being collected digitally
and we are now showing you few examples
of such
um data and how we collect and then an
overview of how we collect the digital
portion this is done by a collaboration
with a bioit it's a company that is
specializes in data management and we
collect the not just the advantage and
test per se of course but also a health
questionnaire
that um looks into the profile of that
person in that particular day symptoms
not numbers of days of symptoms prior to
the testing it collects vaccination
history and it um collects also PCR once
the test is positive as well as random
negative pcrs so that we didn't have to
do each negative PCR but we do collect
random negative pcrs and that PCR that
is positive goes along with a positive
test that the phone camera is collected
and you see that in the top part of of
the slide where there is a camera and
every single test that reaches the hands
of these individuals participants have a
QR code that is interpreted within the
the digital system all right
uh in the top part on the left you see
how aggregated data over the last five
months that we would be we had been
working shows in green negativity and in
red positivity and those Peaks do
correspond exactly with the Peaks you
saw on incidents of Massachusetts and
Chelsea where there were was a surge of
cases of Omicron va1 in in January and
then va2 va5 later on and those are
exactly those two picks that you see as
well here by may we have ba2 and later
on NBA 5. we have some graphical output
on the ethnicity of our participants
showing that indeed there is a majority
half of them are of um a Hispanic origin
and it was interesting in race because
in in purple
um almost half of the people could not
characterize them as a normal sort of
like standardized race it's more like uh
recognize himself as a mix they're not
why they're not African-American but yet
um not Asian but a mix so that that is
an interesting point we have been now
doing uh more than 3 000 tests and you
see them in the graphics on the bottom
we have there the names of the tests
that participate in this particular
study as well and again
um not yet through approval of FDA they
are
um in agreement of course to uh show
some of the preliminary data we will be
showing today
a
interesting point that we want to raise
is the acute phase of the Disease by
which we know it goes from low amount of
virus than it it increases either
plateaus and then goes down and I will
walk you through some interesting cases
we we found in in our study so far and
what you see here in the y-axis is a
Delta CT and the CT Cycles in in the PCR
are normalized by the viral load
normalized to the human gene just to
allow comparison to from sample to
sample because it means the cities will
always be in relation to the amount of
input into the machine so that City
values of importance there the two genes
that we target of the SARS Kobe 2 are in
an open reading frame 1ab and and then
on the in the x-axis you see the
progression of the disease in days and
in this case in dates because we put the
month and the day of the month
and um interestingly enough in the upper
central part there is an unvaccinated
individual and this uh Delta CT over 30
which is 2 to the 30 fold more viruses
than any of the other examples that you
see in the lower part which are just the
other participants so indeed
judging by this quantification the
unvaccinated participant had a
significant more viral load through the
acute phase on the left you see another
case of higher viral load with a
pregnancy case and it resolve itself so
that's why you see that it goes down so
the down means less virus and then you
see on the right an interesting case of
a rebound on a vasculitis comorbidity
case that even though the person
resolved the infection it pumped up
later on
uh on the bottom an example of
um an antiviral treatment where you see
it deep and constant slow slope going
down that's pretty dramatic we've seen
that with several of the treated
participants that nowadays have access
to the antiviral treatment very very
significant change in the shape of the
curve as well and then the last two
um on the bottom left and center right
and Center are two examples of a
participants that are characteristics
this is in the middle a 20 to 30 year
old type of viral load goes up and down
rapidly in in the days are underscore
after the participant ID those are the
numbers of days that we recorded and a
over six year year old on the right so
and a 60 year old on over had sort of a
plateau with a bit of a lingering more
virus so this is just an example of the
quality and type of analysis that we
could derive from the parallel PCR to
antigen now going more into what we're
doing for the antigen test themselves we
have here a cartoon of the methodology
basically in the lab what we do is that
we take either the recombinant nuclear
protein which is a target of a antigen
test or we also work with heat
inactivated chemically inactivated
relevant Source
Delta and Omicron strains
in separately or live virus because we
do have access to bsl3 kind of level of
security and what we do here is that
we're going to do a
um sort of a range of range of
concentrations of these targets and
analyze the image analysis that we
obtained after looking into the
photographs of these various amounts of
input either call it protein or virus
and the virus in for quantification of
the virus we use platforming units per
ml which is a way in the lab to count
how many by viruses we have and the left
side it's the protocol use basically we
do triplicates we do 14 different 2x
Solutions so we have plenty of dots and
you see them
organized in a land more friendly fit
this is just basically the shape of the
the dots or the intensity in pixel and
grayscale and
um that is normalized from zero to one
in the y-axis and in the x-axis you see
the amount of virus meaning the more
intense towards one it's when you have
more virus of course and then you will
have reaching towards the left the limit
of addiction and this limit of detection
the contribution that we do here is very
specific we have a plugin to image J
images a free software made by the NIH
many years ago and that allows the user
being the manufacturer being a
regulatory science person to plug in the
data on the on that intensity and obtain
immediately from that the limit of
detection of that particular experiment
and in this case it's a triplicate
um uh limit of detection on a triplicate
experiment on a chemically inactivated
virus so that is um
a very simple way to immediately obtain
uh values of of a performance that were
not available in in the past
the graphical ways in which we output
this performance are also very friendly
and you have either the langmore curve
itself and here what we did is we
compare three different tests that are
rolled into our study versus one test
that has already been
um approved to be used at home in this
case is called the ongo and the limit of
detection it's in box and whiskers where
the whiskers depict the 95 confidence
interval in what you see here the lower
it is the better it is for accuracy in
this case on go had actually less
accuracy measured side by side in the
lab with viruses or with protein as well
and then the other three that we've been
studying
another piece of the methodology is the
one of the methodology that correlates
the eye side the yes or no binary with
the limit of detection that we just
spoke about and we do that doing
relational models and you will see
immediately what that does basically you
have a fit core curve with the lab
performance and a fit curve with the
same
curve of protein or virus but then you
ask a user to tell you whether they see
or do not see the band The Test band in
the antigen test and that's what we have
graphed on the right and what we do now
is that we merge those two ways of
detection using the dispersion or the
probability of this person of the LOD
and we combine both and those are the
relational models that we will then have
ready for
transcribing the experience in the lab
to the more experience in the real world
which is based only on uh naked eye
assessment
and we will not show you much uh today
about the results but this is all
ongoing and what we see that indeed you
could then do probabilities of
correcting the lab performance on the
right and it turns out that the high
performance zero or one is actually uh
lower the limit of rotation than what
you do in the lab which is a
mathematical
um
detection and then the two get merged to
correct the real or model the the lab
detection to a more real condition and
that's what you see uh as the red line
so we merge the two to generate a new
modeled by
uh lastly the
probability of performance positive or
the percent positive agreement which is
what the regulatory science asks today
about these tests can be modeled
throughout the whole range of uh in this
case PCR which is the gold standard and
what you see here is a regression line
that Associates in the clinical setting
all the pcrs that we have found
um
side by side to the antigen test and the
antigen test is being assessed yes or no
with a binary method and here we see
that for an 80 correspondence you can
have a whole correspondence range of
course uh in this case the CT value is
it depicts less City virus means more
virus and higher CD values is less so
you could see how a hundred percent
performance you will get in as this
given test the as15 from plan for
that uh anything above 30 C uh below 30
cities right or more virus than the 30
CT threshold it's already an 80
correspondence so this kinds of analyzes
allowed
um or will allow a probably a much
faster validation than what we have
today which has been the bottleneck for
approving large numbers of tests and
having them in the hands of users in
that right moment to control and
mitigate epidemics such as the covet or
any other that would come our way
hopefully not the monkey pots but it
looks like we're facing that challenge
as we speak
so to conclude um
or what we have spoken today we have
talked about lateral flow tests being
um
more than just a test digital reporting
device
that the methodology for image analysis
can be used for friendly and can be
supported across different labs and
regions regions of the world if we have
a method or methodology that that is
transportable such as the one we showed
today and and in the hands of
Manufacturers and Regulatory bodies
these techniques could be really
facilitating a validation that doesn't
exist today and is simply using a camera
from a phone could could give that
opportunity
so current validation processes require
these complex and expensive clinical
trials and we do believe that replacing
those very complex trials to a much more
simple and time less time consuming
method would be a good thing to have in
in the hands of everybody including FDA
and uh the complex relational models
that we alluded today use
probability Theory and are a good way a
proper way to translate the lab
performance to a more real-world data
and merge the
the two and eventually model uh what you
could do by not going through a clinical
setting but yet doing a proper lap
performance of a test or a series of
performances just on the lab
side
and with that I would like to thank the
audience and welcome any questions